[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
las elecciones legislativas que va a
celebrar francia a doble vuelta los
próximos 11 y 19 de junio para ello me
acompañan en este estudio guillermo
arenas docente investigador derecho
público miembro del 'think tank'
hemisferios bienvenido gracias encantado
mi compañera beatriz juez corresponsal
del correo aquí en francia y bienvenida
y antonio delgado corresponsal de radio
nacional de españa en francia bienvenida
antonio muchas gracias encantado las
legislativas hoy nuestro asunto en
primera plana
dicen aquí en francia que las elecciones
legislativas son la tercera vuelta de
las presidenciales ya saben que hay un
mes hace un mes macro en realidad al
quinquenio estará hasta 2027 en el
elíseo pero necesita una mayoría
parlamentaria para articular sus
políticas y eso es precisamente lo que
intenta evitar la oposición según los
sondeos la agrupación nacional del epen
podría aumentar considerablemente sus
escaños en la asamblea nacional el
partido presidencial ahora llamado
renacimiento sigue siendo el favorito
por delante de la nueva coalición de
izquierda la gran novedad de estas
legislativas que bajo la etiqueta nueva
unión popular ecologista y social vaya
nombre que se presenta bajo las siglas
nubes intentará plantar cara a la
mayoría del presidente repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja esta cita
electoral diario libération la unión
enciende de nuevo a la izquierda dice el
rotativo que el 78 por ciento de los
electores de izquierdas apoye esta unión
entre insumisos ecologistas socialistas
y comunistas lakua centra esta portada
en la figura de elisabeth board nueva
primera ministra de macrón dice el
rotativo que es la elección de la
eficacia por su capacidad de trabajo y
su rigor l'humanité contrasta en esta
portada partida lo que define como dos
visiones del mundo la de la coalición
presidencial y la de la nueva coalición
de izquierdas como si esa batalla fuera
el centro de estas legislativas bueno
guillermo lo primero para explicar a
nuestros telespectadores a nuestros
oyentes que está en juego en estas
legislativas bueno la mayoría en la
cámara baja del parlamento en la
asamblea nacional y la posibilidad para
el partido o para el movimiento político
que gane estas elecciones de formar un
gobierno eso es algo que no se entiende
muy bien en francia o que se olvida el
sistema político francés sigue siendo
parlamentario es decir que hay un
gobierno que depende de la mayoría en el
parlamento bueno la cámara baja en la
asamblea nacional el presidente de la
república en realidad según la letra de
la constitución no puedo hacer gran cosa
sin un primer ministro y sin un conjunto
de ministros es decir sin un gobierno
en términos de poder reglamentario en
términos de buena capacidad para hacer
adoptar leyes etcétera hace falta una
mayoría parlamentaria para que el
presidente de la república pueda
realizar su programa y esto es realmente
lo que se juega la posibilidad para
emanuel manjón reelegido hace un mes de
tener un gobierno y la capacidad
finalmente de gobernar según él desea
hacerlo y según su programa expliquemos
que el órgano legislativo francés está
compuesto por 577 escaños que
representan los 577 distritos
electorales son a doble vuelta como
hemos dicho el 11 y el 19 de junio por
tanto el mecanismo es el mismo que unas
presidenciales aquí estaremos hablando
beatriz de una especie y 577 pequeñas
presidenciales un sistema que por lo
general suele penalizar en los extremos
si generalmente sí porque también sobre
todo ahora que las elecciones
presidenciales las elecciones
legislativas son seguidas antes cuando
estaban las elecciones era cada siete
años había elecciones presidenciales las
elecciones legislativas a veces eran un
poco como en eeuu en meterme
pero ahora como van tan seguidas como
los acapara hace un mes han votado los
los franceses a macrón es raro que un
mes después voten algo totalmente
diferente entonces generalmente el
partido de del presidente un mes después
lo lógico sería que obtuviera una
mayoría y luego veremos si esta mayoría
se es grande o sea si tiene una mayoría
absoluta una mayoría relativa si tiene
que apoyarse en otros partidos para
gobernar o sí
melanson que es el líder de la izquierda
consigue su sueño que es que haya una
cohabitación y que sea el primer primer
ministro yo sondeos dicen antonios que
va a bajar esa mayoría esa gran mayoría
que tiene macrón aunque la va a
conservar y van a subir un van a subir
tanto la agrupación nacional de marie le
pen como la la coalición de izquierdas
que es la gran novedad de estas
elecciones legislativas y es muy
interesante porque yo creo que en
francia sucede un poco en cualquier país
pero en francia el debate político acaba
estando muy condicionado por el aparato
institucional a través del cual se
vehicula y en este caso de las
elecciones legislativas se ve de manera
muy clara tenemos un sistema un
parlamento que efectivamente es muy
importante que puede terminar el próximo
gobierno del próximo mandato es decir
cambiaría muchísimo el color de la
situación política en francia si en vez
de ganar el partido de macrón ganará la
izquierda que es la principal
alternativa pero eso es muy difícil por
el sistema en sí que efectivamente él no
es un sistema proporcional sino un
sistema en el que en cada una de las 577
circunscripciones se juega una especie
de mini elección presidencial en la que
el ganador se lleva todo el escaño y el
resto de votos van a la basura por así
decirlo entonces en la posición central
del partido de macrón hace que sea muy
probable que mantenga en la mayoría en
el parlamento y por lo tanto el macro
podrá gobernar con cierta comodidad con
un gobierno de su color pero el hecho de
que vayan a subir los extremos incluso
en este sistema es una pista un síntoma
de lo que está ocurriendo en la francia
real más allá de las instituciones que
el país lo vimos a los presidenciales
más polarizado en la que en realidad
macrón representa más o menos a un
tercio del electorado pero hay otros dos
bloques uno en la extrema derecha y otro
en la izquierda que le disputan la
hegemonía política como dice entonces
estamos viendo puede que veamos en estas
legislativas como
la francia tripolar esta especie de
escenario en el que se ha convertido el
país con un hiper centro que controla
macrón muy amplio y luego dos extremos
uno a cada lado vamos a ver el peso de
esos bloques no en las legislativas sí
sí bueno como lo decía antonio cada
circunscripción en cada circunscripción
es decir para cada escaño hay como una
especie de mini presidencial
una característica también importante de
estas elecciones legislativas es que la
tasa de abstención suele ser mucho más
importante que en las presidenciales
precisamente porque un mes después de
haber votado a un presidente de la
república y una forma de desmovilización
de los electores y hace falta además eso
es un tema un poco más técnico pero para
pasar a la segunda vuelta de las
legislativas hace falta haber obtenido
12 5% de los votos de los electores
inscritos es decir que cuanto más
abstención hay más difícil es alcanzar
digamos un número de votos para pasar a
la segunda vuelta y lo que probablemente
vayamos a ver en estas elecciones
legislativas no van a hacer
unas vueltas con tres candidatos y no
segundos vueltas con dos candidatos lo
que evidentemente es una situación que
desfavorece especialmente al candidato
considerado como extremista o
considerado como situado en un extremo y
favorece al candidato central no haya
centrista sino central es decir que los
candidatos de la mayoría de ma
cronológicos candidatos de macrón van a
tener mayor posibilidad para atraer
electores de la derecha clásica que por
ejemplo el candidato de la unión de
izquierdas que ya en una segunda vuelta
no tendrá una reserva de voto suficiente
como para enfrentarse a un candidato de
macrón decíamos la principal novedad
socialistas comunistas verdes e
integrantes de la francia insumisa
consiguieron conformar una colección de
izquierdas algo inédito desde hace
varios años en el escenario político
francés el pacto liderado por la francia
insumisa del ex candidato presidencial
jean luc mélenchon es llamado nueva
unión popular ecologista y social
beatriz que representa esta alianza para
la política francesa
yo pienso que representa un cambio no
hay una esperanza para la izquierda
porque estaban tan divididos o sea por
ejemplo que el partido socialista haya
sacado las elecciones presidenciales un
174 por ciento de los votos cuando fue
el partido que gobernó francia comité y
que gobernó a un francia con françois
hollande dice mucho del estado de la
izquierda por separado
no podían hacer nada juntos veremos si
consiguen algo lo que no sé es si
solamente después de las legislativas se
tirarán otra vez los trastos a la cabeza
y se separaran os o si esto seguirá
aunque dentro del partido socialista ha
creado un cisma está esta coalición y yo
no sé bueno antonio fue corresponsal en
bruselas no sé si desde bruselas se
siguen muchos estudian mucho este tipo
de coaliciones en las que el partido
socialista que es uno de los fundadores
que es europeísta en su adn lo lleva
dentro
ese pacto con me la misión una persona
escéptica me da la sensación de que si
en bruselas se seguirá mucho sobre todo
en el parlamento europeo donde el
partido socialista o el grupo socialista
europeo sigue siendo un grupo muy fuerte
y ahora tienes algunos miembros
franceses que están digamos disueltos en
él a la izquierda del grupo socialista y
además es relevante porque precisamente
uno de los ejes que distingue a mi
lesión de la izquierda convencional es
el discurso crítico pero escéptico quizá
es un término muy desgastado pero un
discurso muy crítico con el consenso
europeísta y el consenso europeísta en
francia era el partido socialista y los
republicanos pero fundamentalmente el
partido socialista quizá se charló en
mucho tiempo atrás pero hay que recordar
que la unión europea actual en gran
parte es fruto de la gestión de font son
y tengan en los años 80 que es junto a
jacques delors que era su ministro de
finanzas el que establece el consenso
que va a establecer la unión monetaria
maastricht y todo aquello contra lo que
se revela la versión bueno pues ahora
los herederos de mitterrand acaban
alineados con el menciones atrás en
estas sentido es muy importante pero
también creo que de alguna forma es la
decantación de un proceso que ya
veníamos viendo ver hace muchos años y
que él lo que era ese partido socialista
me tegan ya no por así de utilizar ese
término del partido socialista digamos
de hollande estaba ya de alguna forma
absorbido por macrón que es el gran
fenómeno que acapara ahora todo ese voto
del centrista o central en el centro
derecha el centro izquierda ya ms hiper
centro de macro les pregunto esta
coalición de izquierdas creen que es
algo coyuntural lo que podría mantenerse
en el tiempo es imposible de saber
habría que tener una bola de cristal lo
que es evidente es que esta coalición
izquierdas es muy oportuna en términos
estratégicos para los pequeños partidos
a los pequeños no a todos los partidos
de izquierdas salvo la france insumisa
es decir los verdes los comunistas y los
ecologistas necesitaban una coalición en
todo caso un acuerdo con la francia y
sumisa para no correr el riesgo de
desaparecer hay que saber que en francia
hay dos grandes vías de financiación
pública de los partidos políticos que
son aquella financiación que viene
después de la presidencial es decir en
función de los resultados a presidencial
y aquella financiación que viene en
función del resto de las legislativas
para un partido como el partido
socialista haber tenido este resultado
tan tan tan tan desastrosa la
presidencial y además obtener menos
diputados que los que tiene ahora
hubiese sido una condena a muerte
financiera entonces era muy importante
para ellos en términos de gestión de
crisis poder tener una y poder tener la
pose de alcanzar escaños
y luego más allá de esta gestión de
crisis inmediata habrá que ver si
funciona han puesto en marcha un
parlamento de la unión popular con
miembros básicamente que es un órgano
básicamente con 500 personalidades
políticas y de la sociedad civil de la
izquierda civil y con representantes de
los socialistas los ecologistas de los
insumisos para intentar crear un órgano
en el cual se puedan hablar y puedan
intentar establecer una forma de diálogo
y construir algo en común para el futuro
pero esto queda efectivamente bueno es
un experimento habrá que ver veracruz es
coyuntural lo que se va a poder mantener
esta serie que yo creo que es coyuntural
yo creo que se van a que no
también creo que va a haber auguró
también tensiones porque la agenda de
milán sión y la de los verdes que quizás
sean el elegir el otro en el otro pilar
y las de mayor que listan siguieron en
las anteriores europeas efectivamente
claro en los verdes de nuevo de nuevo en
el clivaje europeo los verdes es un
partido habrá que ver también por dónde
tiramos
es un partido fundamentalmente
europeísta y su hermano que está
triunfando en alemania es un partido que
se define claramente por la ecología
evidentemente por el europeísmo y eso de
alguna en algún momento va a
cortocircuitar con la agenda de medición
voy a hacer una breve vamos en este
punto enseguida continuamos analizando
las legislativas ayer en primera plana
hasta ahora
[Música]
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
france24
otro punto de vista
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
poniendo el foco en las elecciones
legislativas que va a vivir francia los
días 11 y 19 de junio lo hacemos con
guillermo arenas docente-investigador y
con mis compañeros periodistas beatriz
juez y antonio delgado en la figura del
ib salut born que es la nueva premier
primera ministra al frente del ejecutivo
les ha sorprendido a la elección vea por
el perfil de ella
analizarían todas las quinielas era la
primera que todo el mundo dijo cuando se
empezaron a hacer las quinielas sobre
quién podía ser primero el primer
ministro y por eso es luego también al
final la descartaron porque se le dijo
tanto de ella que iba a ser la primera
ministra pero creo que el macro en lo
que ha elegido es una persona eficaz que
no le haga sombra como por ejemplo la
cia dual bold el lip y que es un poco
más o menos el mismo perfil que el
anterior primer ministro jan castex un
tecnócrata eficaz aquí en francia la
prensa la comparado con una navaja suiza
que es capaz de no ser una ministra de
empleo eficaz una ministra de ecología
más o menos eficaz es verdad que el
perfil ideológico perdona vayan gasteiz
venía más del sarkozysmo y ella viene
más de la izquierdas la única diferencia
pero lo que es
a nivel político yo lo que más o menos
el mismo perfil salvo ideológico pero el
mismo perfil de persona eficaz que va a
poner todo en orden iba a sacar tu
programa antonio como lo ve la
denominación totalmente de acuerdo es un
era previsible en el sentido de que es
un perfil de primer ministro muy de
macrón por lo menos del macro cndh el
segundo la segunda parte del primer
quinquenio una persona que decide que al
lado no tiene que tener a nadie que le
haga sombras no a alguien que haga el
trabajo además elizabeth vor coincide en
encajaba en el casting que el mismo
macrón había establecido antes de las
elecciones es decir es mujer viene de la
izquierda es verdad que también tanteó o
por lo menos esto es lo que dice en los
mentideros de parís para según la opción
de la derecha hago de la derecha sería
buscando más efectivamente pero pero
tenía posiciones muy radicales respecto
a cosas como el matrimonio wallis por
ejemplo lo cual era un hándicap evidente
para el macro nismo para el limón el
aumentan para esa especie de síntesis
general de todas las y de todos los
centros de todas las izquierdas y
derechas en céntricas utilizando un
término que acabo de acuñar
es un perfil muy de macrón una persona
muy eficaz una persona muy competente
una persona en la que el pragmatismo
está por delante de la ideología y una
persona que además puedes vender como
oportuna para este momento en el que el
combate basa con la izquierda puedes
decir que tú también eres un poco de
izquierdas con prisión héctor algunos de
sus ex trabajadores hoy dicen un muy
buen artículo en france enfoque lista de
bornes de las que le puede llamar a las
once y media de la noche no me extraña
nada tiene esa imagen efectivamente de
gran trabajadora una mujer muy técnica
introduciría una diferencia evidente que
conservan castex y es que ella nunca ha
sido electa es decir ya nunca ha
ejercido un cargo electo nunca se ha
presentado a unas elecciones en su vida
ahora en las legislativas con 60 años
son las primeras elecciones a las que se
enfrenta tiene un perfil de tecnócrata
en realidad que no le puedo hacer sombra
a macro porque no tiene un perfil
político y con respecto a lo de la
izquierda que viene de la izquierda ya
nunca ha ocupado una función ni
ministerial ni ejecutiva ni legislativa
de ningún tipo antes de macrón es decir
ella su carrera política
nace en 2017 con elección de mccomb
antes se dice que viene de la izquierda
porque era colaboradora izquierdas pero
ya no tiene un perfil político
si yo quería apuntar que me llama mucho
la atención en en su biografía ella
tiene un relato personal que podría ser
muy vendible políticamente pero que ella
nunca utiliza y eso ya indica que es muy
técnica para ella es descendiente de
judíos que llegan aquí procedentes de
bélgica pro de origen ruso si no me
equivoco y que son víctimas del
holocausto ahora se van a cumplir 40
años de la edad de 80 años perdón de la
redada del velódromo de invierno tanto
su padre como su tío son víctimas de
la shoah del holocausto del genocidio
judío y ella también es un gran ejemplo
de meritocracia en el sentido de que su
padre se suicida en los años 60 sin
dudar una línea de tenía 10 años y en la
repubblica la acoge como fútil de la
nación una especie de huérfana de guerra
precisamente por eso porque su padre
había sido resistente y víctima de la
sua desgracia esa beca que ya estudia
que consigue en una licenciatura en la
politécnica es un gran ejemplo político
un relato que ella podría estar
utilizando para labrarse ese perfil
político y que no lo hace porque ella
está al servicio de macrón y el relato
ya tiene un preso político ya que mi
compañera antonio
en toda la biografía posible por haber
vejado elisabeth board entre los 6.293
candidatos que se presentan este año a
las legislativas en muchas caras
conocidas la primera ministra como
decíamos elizabeth vor y 15 de sus
ministros se juegan mucho al presentarse
los que no logren ganar en sus
circunscripciones saldrían en teoría del
gobierno si uno de ellos no logra el
escaño debería de emitir ya que no
contará con el respaldo en las urnas no
sé si esto es un riesgo o si estar en el
gobierno es una buena vitrina de cara a
las legislativas vea bueno yo creo que
las dos cosas es un riesgo porque por
ejemplo no se darán en este momento que
es el ministro del interior que es un
lío montado con el último lío montado
que tiene es por ir por la champions
league y él y el fiasco que supuso de
organización y se presenta a las
elecciones esos escenarios de selección
es lo que en teoría los locales que es
en la circunscripción pero puede pero a
lo mejor también gente que leo no sé que
le odio que le tienen manía lo que
tenemos pueden votar en contra porque
una mejor no batallan en contra de él es
si fuese una 7 si fuese
presenta si no tuviese ningún cargo pero
solamente porque es el ministro y
quieren
pasarle factura votan contra él no hay
dos casos comprometidos en este gobierno
estarán de acuerdo que son las dos
primeras crisis con la que se ha
encontrado este gobierno uno gerald
armarán como comentar mi compañera vea
de interior por el caso de las centrales
del fiasco de la organización de la
final de la champions league entre el
liverpool y el real madrid el pasado fin
de semana aquí en parís el otro caso es
el de también abad de ministro de
solidaridad es que ha sido acusado de
violación por dos mujeres pero no han
dimitido y ha llegado aquí la nueva
polémica de repente el gobierno acaba de
echar a andar como quien diría y tenemos
dos polémicas importantes antonio sí y
la primera y la más sangrante quizás el
ave damián abad porque puede tener
recorrido y efectivamente esa incluso
antes de que el gobierno tomara posesión
no porque el escándalo ese público
parece que era ya un secreto a voces en
el pequeño país pero ese público difícil
no conocerlo cuanto menos por eso la
secretaria en el escándalo mayor llama
mucho la atención llama mucho la
atención es verdad porque además de
nuevo en un momento en el que macro me
está haciendo un discurso feminista una
mujer del ministro es todavía más claro
y más que en el momento que él michu en
francia también tiene mucho peso hemos
visto no hay que dar nombres pero hemos
visto a compañeros de los medios de
comunicación cuyos carreras han
terminado precisamente por acusaciones
de acoso sexual de abuso sexual años
atrás y tienes un ministro que
evidentemente hay que preservar toda su
presunción de inocencia pero que de
repente tiene una mochila que es ese
escándalo
e incluso si todo es artificio y damián
nada tiene razón al decir que es
inocente es un handicap político muy
importante es muy importante y lo que yo
creo también es que también abad y no se
entiende es su continuidad en el
gobierno si no entendemos la jugada
táctica que supone su fichaje damián
hadad viene de ser el presidente del
grupo los republicanos es decir el
partido de centroderecha tradicional en
la asamblea nacional al ficharlo na
chrome está de alguna forma
escenificando a su conquista
efectivamente desde ese espacio político
el trofeo de caza la señal de que en el
aspecto de los republicanos ya también
ha sido absorbido por el macro nes
fichajes le gustan a macro no vi otro
gran salto lo analizamos antes la
coalición de izquierdas pero otro canal
2 lo haría el partido del epen que
obtendría según los sondeos pues se
habla entre 40 a 60 escaños actualmente
este partido extrema derecha sólo tiene
seis diputados en la asamblea nacional
esta es una de las grandes quejas que
muchos tienen del sistema francés el
peso que tiene la asamblea por ejemplo
este partido que no es el reflejo de lo
que hay en la sociedad guillermo
francia necesita reequilibrar su
representatividad política es un tema
cada vez más candente del que se habla
cada vez más introducir una lo que se
llama en francia una dosis de
proporcional es decir la posibilidad de
que ciertos diputados sean elegidos a
través de un sistema proporcional y no
un sistema mayoritario como el que como
el que impera ahora
que mucha gente cada vez que decimos la
asamblea nacional 577 diputados 6 y
hablamos siempre de una señora mary le
pen que llega que se presenta y llega
siempre a segunda ronda de las
presidenciales de sacchi una distorsión
que mucha gente no la pueden tenía a ver
tampoco tienen regiones tampoco tienen
ciudades importantes es decir el frente
nacional es como muchos partidos
políticas por políticos hoy en día una
plataforma electoral para la
presidencial para que una persona un
líder una líder pueda alcanzar la
presidencia de la república y no hay
nada más no hay no hay no hay cuadros
intermedios no hay capacidad de
formación de militantes para que vayan
ascendiendo etcétera en frente nacional
es una
es decir es una es una institución va
hacia una organización vacía al servicio
de marín open al servicio de lupe de la
dinastía de los pp entonces no tienen ni
grandes ciudades y regiones ni
departamentos no tienen nada es algo una
candidata muy buena en la presidencial
que pierde siempre y efectivamente seis
diputados que es muy poco con respecto
al peso de marie le pen en la
presidencial pero que tampoco es muy
poco con respecto al peso territorial
que tiene es bueno eso
es algo que se podría cambiar y ya en
1986 hubieron unas elecciones las únicas
bajo este sistema va bajo este régimen
con una dosis de proporcional y fue la
primera vez que el frente nacional entró
con la mar y noten el padre de mind open
a la asamblea nacional con un grupo
político importante de 35 diputados se
piensa se estima que ahora en 2022 su
hija pueda alcanzar al menos unos 38 40
diputados rompiendo el récord de
esto se explica también siempre
sorprende mucho que alguien que ha
estado en la en la segunda vuelta a la
presidencia un 41% de los votos vaya a
obtener ahora decimos 35 de 570 77
lo lógico sería que obtuviera no sé o la
mitad o bastantes o por lo menos un
tercio de los votos pero es que eso se
explica por el sistema de las dos
vueltas generalmente
hay 10 candidatos en la primera vuelta
pasan a la segunda vuelta dos o tres de
las legislativas y
generalmente todos los partidos se alían
para que no se retiran se retiran
candidatos para evitar que esa
circunscripción la gane alguien del
frente nacional y entonces hacen algún
cordón sanitario y evitan que pase que
ganen en la circunscripción y eso
explica el hecho de que tengan tan pocos
diputados y la representatividad y yo
creo que está clave también para
entender muchos problemas de francia más
allá del sistema vista crítico es es que
tiene un sistema que prima la
estabilidad del ganador se lo lleva todo
prácticamente todo salvo accidente que
es la cohabitación cuando el presidente
y el parlamento son de color distinto en
general el presidente manda y tiene un
parlamento que es dócil porque tiene la
mayoría pero frente a la última
cohabitación fue en 3 irak ellos pan si
no me equivoco hace 20 años 2002 hace 20
años y ahora ya parece casi imposible
que esto se pudiera dar con las
legislativas además
a las presidenciales con esa prima para
el ganador es que parece imposible que
cuál es el problema que tienes a un
porcentaje de la población sea el voto
de izquierdas o de derechas si las
proyecciones se cumplen y macrón sigue
dominando el parlamento que
prácticamente va a estar representado en
las instituciones de forma testimonial
sin tener ninguna palanca para presionar
sobre el poder y entonces el problema
que eso representa y lo hemos visto en
el primer mandato de macrón es que ese
descontento se acaba canalizando fuera
de las instituciones es decir en la
calle lo vimos con los chalecos
amarillos y eso es lo que lleva a muchos
analistas a pronosticar que este va a
ser un mandato seguramente cómodo en las
instituciones pero muy difícil en la
calle para macro pues muchísimas gracias
a los tres me quedo ya sin tiempo para
más vamos a analizar todo lo que pasa en
las legislativas recuerden los días 11 y
19 de junio en esas legislativas a doble
vuelta muchísimas gracias guillermo
beatriz antonio y a todos ustedes hasta
la semana que viene a quien en primera
plana gracias
[Música]